Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速和大家分享一件目前正在进行、非常令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾好奇如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向持续性收入冲刺挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up today, knitting is more than just a hobby. Yes, you heard me right, knitting.
这些原则都同样适用于你。此外，还有由丽莎亲自送出的精美奖品等你来拿。如果你通过我的专属链接参加挑战赛，还将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一小时指导的机会。你想了解更多吗？当然想啦。快去访问我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好啦，让我们开始今天的节目吧。今天的节目内容：编织不仅仅是一种爱好。是的，你没听错，是编织。
Join me and my guest today as we enter the fascinating world of needles and yarn, where creativity intertwines with mental health. Have you ever wondered how a simple stitch can soothe the mind and uplift the soul? Every knit and purl is a thread of tranquility, where stitching is serenity. Discover how the gentle rhythm of needles can mend the mind and mend the soul one stitch at a time. Stay tuned as we explore and unravel the therapeutic benefits of knitting and the secrets behind
今天，请和我以及我的嘉宾一起，走进这个充满魅力的针线世界——在这里，创造力与心理健康交织在一起。你可曾想过，一针一线如何能抚平心灵、振奋灵魂？每一个织针和反针都是一条宁静的丝线，让编织化为心灵的避风港。探索针线轻柔的节奏如何能一次一针地治愈心灵、抚慰灵魂。请继续收听，我们将一起探索并解开编织的治疗益处，以及每一个线圈和扭转背后的秘密。希望你会觉得这期节目非常有用。嗨，欢迎来到《有志心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，是一名合格的临床心理学家。我喜欢在这档播客中为你带来各种各样的话题。如果你听过前面116期中的任意一期或全部节目，你就会知道这里没有哪两期是相同的。我非常喜欢我们这些合格的、甚至是志向远大的心理学家，如何能将对我们重要的事情融入到我们的执业方式以及我们所服务的人群中。这并不是关于我们自己，但事实上，作为人类，我们在干预过程中绝对扮演着非常重要的角色。在今天的节目中，我邀请到了米娅·霍布斯博士（Dr. Mia Hobbs），
every loop and twist. Hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I like to bring you a variety of topics in this podcast. If you've been here for any or all of the previous 116 episodes, you will know that no two episodes are the same. I love how we as qualified or even aspiring psychologists can begin to bring things that are important to us to the way we practice and the people we serve. It's not about us, but actually as humans, we are absolutely a really important part of the intervention. In today's episode, I am joined by Dr. Mia Hobbs,
她是一位合格的临床心理学家，也是“为了心理健康的编织”（knitting for mental well-being）倡导者。这是一场非常迷人的交谈，我非常喜欢。节目结束后，我期待与大家再次交流。嗨，米娅，很高兴今天你能来到播客做客，谢谢你加入我们。嗨，谢谢邀请我。我们最初是在 Instagram 上结缘的，你在上面倡导编织的美丽和益处，从心理健康的角度来看，这显然很有趣。但你之所以吸引我的眼球，是因为你是一位同样也是编织狂热爱好者的临床心理学家，对吧？是的，没错。不瞒你说，我在工作中越来越频繁地使用编织了。我想我当初加入 Instagram 纯粹是为了看编织相关的内容，当时在2017年左右，我并不觉得 Instagram 上有什么特别适合我的东西。
a qualified clinical psychologist and a knitting for mental well-being advocate it's a fascinating chat and I loved it I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side of this hi Mia lovely to have you here on the podcast today thank you for joining us hi thanks for having me so we first crossed paths on Instagram um where you advocate the beauty and the benefit of knitting which is obviously interesting from a mental health perspective but you caught my eye because you're a clinical psychologist who's also a big fan of knitting aren't you yeah that's right no I've been using um knitting more and more in my work but I joined Instagram I guess for the knitting having not thought there was anything on Instagram particularly for me back in I think 2017.
我只是喜欢社交媒体那种丰富多彩且垂直细分的特点。是的，我太喜欢了。所以在我们深入探讨编织之前，能跟我们聊聊你自己以及你是如何走上心理学这条路的吗？当然可以。我想我大概是在读心理学本科的大部分时间里，就认定自己想成为一名临床心理学家的。我在本科第三年做了一年的实习，当时在一个为自闭症儿童服务的学校工作。我曾经了解过教育心理学，但我发现自己更倾向于做心理干预，而教育心理学专业的心理学家往往没有那么多机会做干预。在那之后，我就走上了更偏向临床的路线。我想在进入伦敦大学东伦敦大学（UEL）培训之前，我做过好几份助理心理学家的工作。
I just love how varied and niche social media can be yeah I love it. So before we plough into knitting could we hear a little bit about you and how you got into psychology please? Sure so I think I knew I wanted to be a clinical psychologist about maybe most of the way through my undergraduate psychology degree. I did a year kind of a placement year in my third year in undergrad and was working in a school with kids with autism and I was looking into educational psychology but I was more I think attracted to doing more intervention than I think maybe educational psychologists often have the opportunity to do and then after that yeah took a more kind of clinical route. And I think I did a couple of assistant psychologist posts before then training at UEL in London.
太棒了。你是什么时候获得资格认证的？我是2008年获得资格认证的。所以我其实算不出来这到现在到底有多少年了。那意味着你获得资格认证的那年正是我开始（从业）的那一年，所以我们有过一点交集。但是，是的，这已经是很多年前的事了。我想我大概是在15年前左右开始的，差不多就是那样。所以你大概也是在15年前左右获得资格认证的吧。太好了。你提到过你和儿童及青少年一起工作，自从获得资格认证以来你一直都在做这个吗？是的，所以我只……我偶尔会在私人诊所里接待成年人，但我从2008年获得资格认证一直到2017年都在英国国民保健制度（NHS）工作，这期间全部都是……是的，和儿童及青少年在一起，一部分是在小学里，然后是在
Perfect. When did you qualify? I qualified in 2008. So I don't actually know how many years that is now. That means that you qualified the year that I I started so we had a little bit of overlap but um yes quite some years now it's what I think I'm about I was I think I was starting about 15 years ago something like that so you probably qualified about 15 years ago something like that lovely and you mentioned that you work with children and young people have you done that since qualifying yes so I've only I've I see occasionally I will see an adult in private practice but I've I've worked in the NHS from 2008 when I qualified to 2017 and that was all um yeah with children and young people in partly in primary schools and then in
更综合的儿童和青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）机构里。我可以问问，是什么因素促使你决定离开 NHS 的吗？我问这话没有任何挖苦或施压的意思，因为我自己也做过同样的选择。如果你觉得可以公开谈论这个，我很乐意了解，我相信我们的听众也一定很想知道。当然可以，这确实是一个非常艰难的决定。而且这其实也是我第一次刻意通过一个编织项目来度过我生活中的转型期。我想我以前其实也做过编织，但在此之前并没有刻意去想过它的作用。但当我离开 NHS 时，我所在的团队经历了很多变故——就像大多数 NHS 团队一样。在休完产假、带着第二个孩子兼职重返工作岗位后，我觉得自己很难
kind of more generic camps. Can I ask what factors were involved in your decision to leave the NHS and that's with no barbs or kind of pressure because I've done the same myself like if that feels okay for you to answer it I'd love to know and I'm sure our audience would love to know too. Yeah absolutely it was a really tough decision and it was a decision actually that like I think that was also the time that was the first time I intentionally used a knitting project to get me through a transition in like my life I think I think I'd done it but not really thought about it intentionally before that but when I left the NHS I think the team I was working in there had been a lot of changes as most NHS teams I'd gone back after having my second child part-time and I think was struggling
应对 CAMHS 团队中层角色的压力。我们一方面要承担那种需要接待更严重、高风险临床病例的职责，同时还要督导团队中资历较浅的成员。除此之外，还要参加一些更偏向管理性质的会议，而所有这一切都是在兼职的情况下进行的。这让我感到巨大的压力，感觉时间刚刚好够做完所有那些必须做的事情，以达到接待客户数量的目标、督导每个人。但却没有足够的时间去探索任何超出这一范围的东西，比如个人兴趣或持续专业发展（CPD），这真的太难了。我的丈夫是一名 NHS 的医生，令人难过的是，我觉得这种工作状态对我们的家庭来说实在不可持续。我想当时也是冬天，我的孩子经常生病。从这个意义上说，那是一个极其艰难的决定。团队里有些事情真的非常无益，我并不认同，我感到相当沮丧，却又无能为力。所以当时感觉这是一个非常令人伤心的决定，并不是我真正想做的，而且
with being the kind of middle level of the CAMHS team where we were seeing, you know, we were of the level that we're expected to take the more serious, risky clinical cases at the same time as supervising more junior members of the team. Also then attending some kind of more management type meetings and all of that in only part time, which felt like a lot of pressure and that there was enough, just about enough time to do all the things you kind of had to do to hit all of the targets of how many clients you're seeing. Are you supervising everybody? But not enough time to explore anything kind of above that in terms of like interest or CPD or that was really difficult. And I'm married to an NHS doctor and I felt like it was not really sustainable, sadly, for our family. I think it had also been winter and my kids had been sick very often um so in that sense it was a really difficult there was some things in the team that were really unhelpful and I didn't really agree with I felt quite frustrated I think and not being able to do anything about it so it felt like a very sad decision at the time and wasn't really one that I wanted to make and it
从理智上讲，这种离开方式并不明智，因为我事先并没有建立好私人诊所的工作。当然，我有三个月的通知期，所以我可以把事情稍微筹备运转起来，但这并不是一个经过精心策划的离职。不过我知道，相比于去找另一份 NHS 的工作，私人工作对家庭生活来说会更有灵活性。所以正是在那个时间点，我离开了，向未知迈出了勇敢的一步。我想，是的，回到编织这方面，我觉得开办私人诊所让我能够更加灵活，并且在探索其他兴趣时更有创新精神，我想是这样的。是的，绝对是这样的。就在今天，你知道吗，有一个有志成为记者的年轻人给我发信息说：“你能帮我做这个研究吗？”
was not done in a sensible way in the sense that um I didn't really have private work set up beforehand obviously I had a three-month notice period so I could get things kind of a bit up and running but I didn't really it wasn't really a planned departure um but I knew that private work was going to be more flexible for family life rather than finding another NHS job so that was the point at which I kind of left and took a leap into the unknown and I think yeah in terms of going back to the knitting side of things I feel like being in private practice has allowed me to be a bit more kind of flexible and innovative I suppose in terms of exploring other interests yeah yeah absolutely even today you know an aspiring journalist messaged me and said could you help with this research and
听起来真的非常非常有趣，我特别想参与，所以我马上就答应了。但显然，当我们处于受雇状态时，这会让事情变得复杂得多。所以，是的，我完全理解你。当年我离开 NHS 的时候，也简直快把我的心给碎了。那是一个我热切信仰的组织，我认为它在资源极度紧缺的情况下，为全国——整个英国的许许多多患者提供了一项非常令人印象深刻的服务。但你知道，我们绝对需要照顾好我们自己的福祉以及我们家人的需求。而且，你知道，这可能不是我们永远都会做的事，也可能是我们选择永远不再回去的事。但无论如何，我们首先是人，其次才是心理学家，我们必须拥有良好的工作与生活平衡。
it sounded really really interesting and I really wanted to do it and so I've been like yes but obviously when we're in an employed capacity it makes that much trickier um so yeah I hear you like damn near broke my heart when I left the NHS as well it's an organization that I passionately believe in and I think that it offers a really pretty impressive service in very stretched resources um to many many patients across the the country across the UK for that matter but it's you know we absolutely need to be looking after that our own well-being and the needs of our own family and you know it may not be something that we do forever it may be something that we you know choose to stay away from forever but you know we we are people first and and psychologists second and we've got to have good work-life balance.
是的，我觉得这确实带来了……你知道的，有很多好处。比如我可以简单地决定不缺席孩子们的任何一场学校集会、运动会或者诸如此类的活动。对我来说，我当时能够做到这一点，这真是太幸运了。而且，是的，这可能不会是一辈子的状态。就像你说的，我愿意认为自己在某个时间点还会回到 NHS，但……是的，我们走着瞧吧。是的，我懂你的意思。就像学校突然在周五下午两点安排了一场额外的音乐集会，然后你会想：“哦，好吧，我可以去。”但我心里非常清楚，如果我不是在私人诊所工作，我绝对去不了，那将会是一个大麻烦。是的，完全是这样。而且在每个学期结束时，似乎总会有一堆这种必须出席的额外活动。对于我的大孩子来说，我们现在正接近六年级的尾声，随后还会有更多诸如此类的告别活动。那么，跟我们聊聊你和编织的故事吧。你是什么时候开始学习编织的？
Yeah, and I feel like that has, you know, there are a lot of benefits, I suppose, in terms of, you know, being able to just decide that I won't miss any of my kids' assemblies or sports days or things like that, that, you know, for me, I was able to do that at that point um and that was fortunate and yeah and it might not be forever yeah like you say that um I would like to think I'll go back to the NHS at some point but yeah we'll see yeah I hear you like when they randomly
我想我学的时候……我记得小时候有一些唐老鸭图案的编织针，我妈妈是一个断断续续会编织的人。她……你知道的，你偶尔会看着她，她只是坐在那里咔哒咔哒地敲着针。我当时觉得，她只是把那些针碰在一起，然后像变魔术一样就织出东西来了。我要求尝试一下，她就会帮我，然后我会织出一些非常紧绷、让人沮丧的小东西，大概只有老鼠毯子那么大。所以我想我在童年时期这样做过好几次，就像我的孩子们也做过的那样。但这并没有坚持下来。我总是对用双手制作东西很感兴趣。比如我会玩……我不知道，菲莫软陶（Fimo），我还经历过十字绣的阶段。我总是在做类似的事情。我觉得我大脑里有一部分渴望有一个项目，这个项目与……我不知道，与工作或任何真正重要的事情无关，仅仅是一件微小而有创造力的事情。
throw in an extra music assembly at 2 p.m on a Friday and you're like oh well I can go but I'm acutely aware that I wouldn't be able to if I wasn't in private practice that would be a bit more of a struggle yeah exactly and there just seems to be at the end of every term a whole bunch of those extra things where you have to show up we're approaching the end of year six now for my eldest and then there's even more kind of leaving stuff um that happens as well um so tell us about you and knitting when did you first start to learn to knit? So I think I learned I remember having some like Donald Duck knitting needles as a child and my mum was a knitter kind of on off knitter and she um she would you know periodically you just like kind
哦，米娅，你可是正念的早期践行者啊。对，完全是这样的。但我当时并没有以任何正式的方式去思考它。直到我开始在 UEL 接受培训时——实际上是我妈妈认识了一个人，那人的女儿也读了临床心理学的博士学位。这位心理学实习生去学了砌砖，因为她内心有着极其强烈的渴望去……我甚至不知道她是不是真的需要砌一面砖墙，但她有强烈的愿望去做一件与心理学完全无关的事情。就在那个时候，我妈妈正处于一个热爱编织的时期，沙发扶手上放着披肩，如果你觉得冷的话……
of watch her and she just could be clicking I remember thinking she's just clicking those needles together and it's kind of just happening by magic and I would ask to try and she'd help me and I'd make some very tight and frustrating little knitting like a kind of the size of a mouse blanket um so I think I did that a few times throughout childhood like my kids have also done and didn't you know it didn't stick I was always attracted to making things with my hands like I would do I don't know Fimo I had a cross stitch phase I was always doing something like that and I feel like there was a part of my brain that wanted like a project that was unrelated to, I don't know, work or anything that mattered, really. Just like a little creative thing.
所以当时我在她家，因为觉得冷，就把那条披肩裹在身上。她说：“你可以自己织一条。我想你应该学学编织。”我说：“好吧，好吧。”说实话，这纯粹是为了让她安静下来。于是她教了我针法。我觉得人的双手总是能记住，即使大脑记不住。有点像当我拿出我以前常拉的单簧管时，我的双手能记起怎么演奏，尽管我觉得自己已经看不懂乐谱了。所以她教了我怎么做。在搭乘回伦敦的火车之前，我们去了约翰·刘易斯百货公司（John Lewis）买了一些毛线。当时我正准备参加第一年的期末考试。那是一条三角形的披肩，我其实现在还留着它。它从大约五针开始，
Oh, you were an early adopter for mindfulness, Mia. Yeah, exactly. But I think I didn't really think about it in any formal way and then when I it was actually when I started um training at UEL my mum's had met somebody whose daughter had also done the clinical psychology doctorate and this um trainee psychologist had learned to bricklay because she really had this strong desire to I don't even know if she needed a brick wall, but that she had a strong desire to do something that was completely unrelated to psychology. And at that point, my mum was in a phase of knitting at that time and had, you know, shawls on the arm of the sofa that if you were cold.
然后逐渐变得越来越大。现在它的翼展已经……你知道的，非常巨大，大概有几米宽。它从很小开始织起其实挺好的，这样当我还不太会编织时，织完一行非常快。每当我复习间隙休息时，我就织上两行，然后再回去复习。我一直觉得这就像是在使用我大脑中一个截然不同的部分，与我的大部分工作所要求的部分截然不同——虽然它现在依然存在于我的工作中，但在培训期间尤其明显，因为那时你需要死记硬背大量信息，进行大量的思考、分析和交谈。而这仅仅是一个非常不同的、我感觉是大脑中不同部分的体验。我觉得它好像打开了一扇不同的暗门，当我织一会儿毛织物时，不同的想法就会涌现出来。所以现在，我经常会带一些编织活儿去我的线下诊所。在有人走进房间之前，我会坐上五分钟，拿出我的
So I was at her house and I just put wrapped shawl around me because I was cold. And she said, you could make one of those. I think you should learn to knit and I said okay fine like just to kind of keep her quiet really to be honest and um so she showed me the stitches I think my hands I always feel like people's hands remember even if their brains don't a bit like when I get my clarinet out that I used to play my kind of hands can remember even though I feel like I can't read music anymore um so she showed me how to do things and before I got on the train back to London we went to John Lewis and bought some yarn and I was just about to do my first year exams at the time and I feel like it was a triangular shawl I actually still have it so it starts off with like five stitches and
编织活儿开始织，然后我就会想：“哦，也许我应该问问他们关于这件事的情况，”或者会有一些全新的想法浮现在我脑海中，这是我原本没有想过的，如果我刻意去绞尽脑汁思考也绝对想不出来的。所以这就是我开始编织的时间。而且碰巧的是，我培训课程中的另外几个女孩也……其中有些人说是我教她们编织的，这可能是真的，也可能是假的。我记得我的朋友瑞秋，她的奶奶曾教过她编织，而且她……我不知道，她家里有一些编织用品。所以我们有几个人经常会随机聚在一起。比如一起织一会儿，聊一会儿。我想，这可以说是稍微煽动了心中的火苗吧。但这只是我在家里复习间隙悄悄做的一件事，而且直到很久以后，我才真正意识到它对我的心理健康有多大帮助。但这就是一切的起点。
then gets gradually bigger and bigger and bigger and the wingspan of this thing is now you know huge like a couple of meters maybe and um it was quite good that it started small so I could just when I was new at knitting just do a row was very quick and when I was having a break in my revision I would just do a couple of rows and then I go back to my revision and I felt I've always felt like it is like using a very different part of my brain to what was required of a lot of me. It is still in my job now, but also particularly in training where you're kind of cramming information in and you're doing a lot of thinking and analysing and talking. And this was just a very different, I felt, part of my brain and I feel like it kind of opens a different trap door and then different thoughts emerge if I do a bit of knitting. So often now I'll bring some knitting with me to my face-to-face clinic and before somebody comes into the room I just sit for five minutes and get my
我太喜欢这个故事了，我特别喜欢另一个实习生突然说“我需要去砌一面砖墙”的那个画面，太搞笑了。我想……我不知道这个人是谁，也不知道他们家里是不是真的杵着这么一面挡路的砖墙，但我宁愿相信他们真的有。因为我觉得，很多时候我们所做的工作，你不见得能立刻看到那种有形的结果，对吧？你或许能有一种切身的感受，意识到我们所做事情的重要意义。所以，也许这其中包含着这样一种心理需求：“我需要砌一面砖墙”、“我想织一件毛衣”——我需要做点什么。但我更喜欢这种理念：你可以把它用作一种从心理治疗会话中减压的方式，
knitting out and then I think, oh maybe I'll just ask them about this thing or something new will come to me that I hadn't thought about and wouldn't have thought about if I was deliberately trying to think about it I think so that was when I started and actually as it happens a couple of other girls on my training course had also so some of them say I taught them to knit which may or may not be true. I remember my friend Rachel, her grandma had taught her to knit and she, I don't know, had some knitting at home. So a few of us used to randomly. Like knit a bit together, we'll talk a bit about it. So that kind of, I think, fanned the flame a little bit. But it was just something I did in revision breaks quietly at home and I don't think I realized how helpful it was for my kind of mental well-being until much later really but that was where it started
同时也是为接下来的心理治疗会话做好心理建设的一种方式。所以它最终成为了编织成品的一部分，不是吗？所有那些……我想这也是为什么它如此具有唤起力。你知道，我至今仍然记得在读七年级（大概11岁）的学校旅行时，去参观贝叶挂毯（Bayeux Tapestry）的情景。那种凝聚了所有人、所有小时数、双手的劳动以及倾注在创作中的奉献精神的理念……我认为这正是手工制作真正的美丽所在。当我生下大宝时，我的一个朋友（实际上她也是一名临床心理学家）送给我一些漂亮的毯子和针织泰迪熊之类的东西。那种礼物，你很难用言语去表达它是多么地充满力量。因为
I love that and I love the idea of of the other trainee suddenly being like I need to build a brick wall so funny I guess I don't know who this person is and whether they have this brick wall it's so funny I guess I don't know who this person is and whether they have this brick wall that's actively in the way in their garden I like to think they do yeah because I guess a lot often a lot of the work we do you don't necessarily get that tangible result do you you might get a felt sense of actually the importance of what we do but so maybe there's something around you know I need to build a brick wall I want to knit a jumper like I need to do something but I love the idea that you can kind of use it as a way of decompressing from therapy sessions
你需要提前很久预定，对吧？你不能凭空突然变出那样一件东西。这代表着有人一直把你放在心上，有人选择用正念时刻惦记着你——甚至当他们在做规划的时候，当他们去毛线店的时候，以及之后每次他们低头编织的时候。这真的是太美好了。是的，而且当你自己动手做的时候，你才会真正……你知道的，意识到别人花费了多少个小时的空闲时间来做这件事，或者……挑选正确的颜色、正确的毛线。我想这正是让我意识到它有多大益处、以及如何能有意识地使用它的原因之一。那是我在 NHS 的最后一份工作，当时我在 CAMHS 团队里，我的一个同事当时正怀着双胞胎。这些孩子非常特别，因为那是她在战胜乳腺癌之后诞生的。她是一个
but also kind of building your mind up for therapy sessions as well and so that becomes kind of part of the the knitted product doesn't it that all of those I think it's why it's so evocative you know I remember still going to see the Bay of Tapestry um on my school trip when I was in year seven so I was like 11 um but the idea that all of the people and all of the hours and the hands and the work and the dedication that went into creating that. And I think that's what the real beauty of handmade is. When I had my first born, one of my friends who was actually a clinical psychologist, gave me some beautiful blankets and kind of knitted teddies and things and it's just it's just a gift that is really tricky to put into words how powerful that is because
非常、非常有个性、也是团队里深受大家喜爱的一员。很多人找到我，因为他们知道我会编织，他们说：“哦，我真的很想为这些宝宝织点东西，你能帮我做点什么吗？”当时我在想，其实我不确定这些可怜的宝宝是否需要15件半成品的开衫，或者……你知道的，新生儿长得太快了，对吧？你会付出巨大的努力，结果他们只穿了五分钟。所以我说：“听着，为什么不让我买点毛线，然后我们所有人一起来织方块呢？”其实在我还是个实习生、刚开始学编织的时候，在我最后一次实习的地方，那里的整个团队曾为我做过一个神奇的……像拼布靠垫一样的东西，他们把它全部缝合在了一起。团队里的每个成员都为这个拼布靠垫织了一小块。其中有些人
you need to pre-order that don't you you know you can't just suddenly have that it's it's being held in mind and somebody choosing to mindfully holding you hold your mind even whilst they're doing the planning even whilst they're going to the wool shop you know and then every time they're knitting that's really lovely. Yeah and I think when you do it you really you know you realize just how many hours of somebody's free time they've spent doing this thing or, you know, choosing the right colour or the right yarn or, you know. And I think that was one of the things that really made me realise how beneficial it was and how you could use it very intentionally. It was when I was part of my last NHS job in the CAMHS team, there was a colleague of mine who was having twins and they were very special babies because they were following her breast cancer and she was a
针织技术其实相当糟糕，他们还拍了照片作为证据，证明连那位咨询精神科医生都亲自下场织了几针。原本某某人还想把活儿拿回家让他妻子代劳，但大家最后说服了他，让他相信自己其实也学得会编织。那真是一份太棒的礼物了，我直到现在还留着它。所以，是的，正是这个经历启发了我。虽然我并没有强迫任何人加入，但很多人——或者说，至少有一个人，她是那对双胞胎父母的挚友——很多很多人聚到了一起。其中有许多人以前织过一点，但也有很多人完全不会。我们大家在午休时坐在一起，哪怕只有10到15分钟，
very, you know, very big character and a loved member of the team and we, lots of people came up to me because they knew I knitted and they said, oh I'd really like to knit something for these babies, could you help me do something? And and I was thinking actually I'm not sure these poor babies need like 15 half finished cardigans or um and you know they grow so quickly don't they newborns that um you could put in a lot of effort and make something they would only wear for five minutes so I said look why don't I buy some yarn and we'll all we can knit squares and I had actually as a trainee as I was a knitter and in my last placement um all of the team there had made me this amazing um like patchwork cushion and they'd sewn it all together and each of the members of the team had knitted a bit of this patchwork cushion and some
大家也会放下手中的工作，坐在员工休息室里而不是办公桌前，织上一会儿。这打开了完全不同的话题，让大家有了一段不谈工作的纯粹时间。我清楚地注意到，这极大地提升了团队的士气。所以我想，正是这个经历让我开始更严肃地思考：我究竟能不能把它当作我心理治疗工作的一部分呢？哦，这实在是太美妙了。这甚至让我有点热泪盈眶——一想到团队里的每个人都为你织了一个方块。我懂！那真的非常有力量，真的非常美妙，而且让人感到无比温暖。你会在与客户的面谈中用到这个吗？比如你们会不会一起织毛线，然后客户把作品带走，这样他们就能把
of them were you know quite dodgy knitters and they'd taken photographic evidence to show that even the consultant psychiatrist had done some knitting and so and so had been tempted to take it home and get his wife to do it but they'd actually persuaded him he could learn to knit and it was such an amazing gift I've still got it now and yeah so that was what inspired me so I didn't make anyone join in but lots of well one person maybe um he was a very good friend of the person whose babies they were lots of people came together and I so there were many people who'd done a bit of knitting before but lots of people who hadn't and we all kind of sat together at lunchtime and even if it was like 10-15 minutes
这作为与你共同工作的有形产物时刻记在心里？是的，我确实这样做过。我最近刚完成了一条治疗毯，这是我和一个客户目前正在共同制作的。我们俩都织了方块并将它们缝合在了一起。有时我们会把编织作为建立关系策略的一部分，而最终，一旦他们觉得开口说话感到自适了，他们的编织针就不会掏得那么频繁了。但，是的，这真的很美妙。其实我在不同的工作场所都这样做过好几次，我们一起制作一条毯子，当它有了一个明确的目的时，那种感觉真的很棒。而且……是的，有些人是我教他们编织的，或者帮他们重新唤醒了记忆，然后他们离开后，这就变成了一种
people put their work down they sat in the staff room not at their desks and did a bit of knitting and it opened up different conversations and people had a bit of non-working time and I really noticed how it made a big difference to team morale so I think that was you know what made me think about more seriously, could I actually use it as part of my therapy work? Really? Oh, that's just so lovely. And that brought a little tear to my eye, the idea that everybody in the team knitted you a square. I know! That's really, really powerful, really lovely and just really, really nice. Do you ever use that in session with clients do you ever kind of knit together and then the client takes away the work with them so that they can kind of hold that
类似过渡客体的东西，但又是他们需要在心理治疗会话中紧紧抓住的东西——用来支撑他们坚持到下一周，或者撑过假期之类的一段时期，或者为生命中重要的人亲手制作一件物品，以此来……是的，帮助他们感受到与对方的亲密感。另外，我想我们许多作为编织爱好者的人，最初都是由家里的长辈教导的，这能帮助我们拉近与其他人——比如那些可能已经不在我们身边的人——的距离。所以我觉得，我发现它在很多方面都……是的，真的非常有用。而且我也开始在自己的播客中与人们探讨为什么他们要编织、编织如何有益于他们的心理健康。大家分享了许多精彩绝伦的故事，因为我认为有太多的轶事证据表明，编织对你的心理健康有着巨大的益处。是的。就在我们按下录音键之前，你还在试图教我编织。
in mind as a tangible product of the work they've done with you yes I have done that um and have recently finished like a therapy blanket that I'm making with a client at the moment where we've both knitted squares and put them together and sometimes we do a bit of knitting as part of you know an engagement strategy and then eventually once they feel comfortable talking their knitting needles don't come out so often but yeah it's been you know lovely I've done it a few times actually in different workplaces where we've made a blanket together and that has felt nice when it's had a purpose I think um yeah and some people I've taught them how to knit or maybe reminded them and then they've gone away and it's been a a kind of almost like a transitional object but something that they've needed to hold on to through therapy sessions like to keep them
这立刻就把我带回了祖母家的扶手椅上，当时我依偎在椅子里，因为她是一个狂热的编织爱好者。遗憾的是，似乎只有当她的癌症病情加重时，她才真正停下来。但她的身边总是放着一个装满编织针、项目、毛线球的编织包。我觉得这些几乎也是代代相传的非常美好的东西，不是吗？这样你就可以把别人没织完的毛线活儿接力完成。我现在有点后悔当时没有想到去这么做……我不知道那些东西现在在哪里了，但，是的，这真的非常有力量，对吧？还有那种感觉——也许我的手指确实还记得，我只是需要有人帮我起针，我当时就是在起针那里卡壳了。
going until the next week or over a break for example or to make something for a significant person in their life to kind of um yeah help them feel close to them also I think a lot of us as knitters were taught by family members and it helps us feel closer to other people you know maybe who aren't with us anymore so I think there's lots of ways in which I found it's been um yeah really helpful and I've also um started having these conversations on my own podcast with people about why they knit and how it benefits their mental health and people have shared some amazing stories because I think there's just so much anecdotal evidence that knitting can be hugely beneficial to your mental health. Yeah. Just before we hit record, you were trying to teach me to knit.
是的，我的邻居……其实现在有一个非常了不起的组织，他们的总部设在美国，但世界各地都有他们的编织志愿者，名字叫“松散线头”（Loose Ends）。他们的创立就是围绕着这样一个痛点：当亲人由于离世或无法再继续编织，留下了未完成的项目时怎么办？所以现在，他们会将这些未完成的项目与那些志愿贡献自己技能的“终结者”（finishers）进行匹配。你可以向他们报名做志愿者，说我会做……我不知道，比如编织和钩针，然后他们会找到某个不会编织的人所留下的项目，接着志愿者会帮他们完成。在我的播客中采访他们时，听到这些故事真的太惊人了。我之前只考虑过，对于正处于悲痛中的人来说，能把这件物品完成会是多么美好的一件事，也许那是给他们
And it did immediately transport me to being cosied up in an armchair at my granny's house because she was an avid knitter. And she only really seemed to stop as her cancer advanced unfortunately but she always just had a knitting bag full of knitting the needles and you know projects and and balls of wool and I think those are almost really nice things to pass down the generation as well aren't they so that you can kind of finish someone's knitting and I'm kind of a bit sad now that I didn't think to do that um I don't know where they are now but yeah like it's really powerful isn't it and you know that idea that maybe my fingers do remember I just need to I need to have some help with casting on that's where I was struggling
孙辈的泰迪熊或者诸如此类的东西。但我没有想到的是，许多申请成为“终结者”的人，其实也是那些曾经经历过悲痛失去亲人的人，或者是想要为他人做点好事的人。所以这是一个了不起的项目，哦，这简直就是给《修复大厅》（Repair Shop）量身定制的题材。这绝对能拍成一个精彩绝伦的系列节目，你应该把这个作为一个电视创意推销出去，达芬娜·麦考尔（Davina McCall）完全可以主持这个节目，毫无疑问。或者克劳迪娅·温克尔曼（Claudia Winkleman）也可以，她那么喜欢针织衫。这绝对大有可为。克斯蒂（Kirsty），她也能胜任，她挺喜欢编织的，不是吗？这绝对大有搞头。
yeah my neighbor no there's actually an amazing um organization now they're based in the US but they've got knitters all over the world um called loose ends who were based around that exact um issue of a loved one no longer being able to knit or not being around anymore and having an unfinished project so now they have they match projects with finishers who volunteer their kind of skills so you can volunteer for them and say I can do I don't know knitting and crochet and they find a project that somebody's been left with who doesn't knit and then people finish them and it's it was amazing to speak to them for my podcast about you know the I had thought about how nice it would be for the person who had who was grieving to have this item finished maybe it was a teddy bear for their
这真的是一个非常可爱的想法。这让我想起我外婆为我织的一件色彩极其鲜艳的彩虹毛衣。她还给我织过一件《小马宝莉》（My Little Pony）毛衣。但我只穿过一两次，因为我不小心把它落在度假的地方了。所有那些时间投入，我再也找不回它了。而且，说实话，挺难过的。
the grandchild or something like that but what I hadn't thought about was the um that lots of the people who'd applied to be finishers were actually also people who'd lost somebody through grief or wanted to do something nice for another person so it's an amazing project but oh that's that's got repair shop written all over it hasn't been watched that would make a fantastic series you should pitch that as a as a tv idea because Davina McCall could present that, surely. Maybe Claudia Wilkin with her love of knitwear. Like, that's got legs. Kirsty, she could do it. She loves a bit of knitting, doesn't she? That's got legs, that has.
我想我穿它的时候确实非常开心。但是，唉，伤心的时刻，伤心的时刻。丢失手工编织的物品真的很难受。是的，我差点弄丢过一件……我刚织好这件开衫，而且在那之前我当编织爱好者已经挺长一段时间了，但一直没有尝试过织成衣。是的，我差点弄丢过一……我刚织好这件开衫，而且在那之前我当编织爱好者已经挺长一段时间了，但一直没有尝试过织成衣。我织了这件开衫，并且为它感到非常骄傲。它是我做出的第一批可以穿出门的衣服之一。结果它最后掉在了一个袋子里，而那个袋子落在了从巴塞罗那机场开出的巴士上……后来我又找回它了。不过，是的，当时以为丢了的那几天真的很难过，心想这回彻底没了。
That's a really lovely idea. And it was making me think about a fantastic rainbow bright jumper that my granny knitted me. And she also knitted me a My Little Pony jumper. But I only ever got to wear it once or twice, because I left it on holiday. All of those hours, I never got it back. And, you know, sad.
我太喜欢你失而复得的结局了。你究竟是怎么开始织一件毛衣的？它是把不同的片缝合在一起的吗？还是说是一气呵成的？它们可以是缝合在一起的。从你身上我有点看不出来。我觉得你的开衫是拼片组成的。对。但是，举个例子，我身上现在穿的这件毛衣是从领口开始起针，然后圈织的。接着一直往下织到肩膀，然后把袖子挑出来放在一旁挂着，再接着往下织衣身。所以它基本上是由三个筒状部分组成的。通常我更喜欢把它们全部连成一体织出来，因为这样你可以在编织的过程中随时试穿，从而知道它够不够长，或者尺寸合不合适，这样会容易得多。哦，这真的太聪明了！太聪明了！生活成本危机对编织
I guess I really enjoyed it when I wore it. But, yeah, sad times, sad times. It's tough to lose hand knitted items. Yeah, I nearly lost a, I'd just finished knitting this cardigan and I'd not been knitting. It was quite a long time of me being a knitter before I knitted items yeah I nearly lost a um I'd just finished knitting this cardigan and I'd not been knitting it was quite a long time of me being a knitter before I knitted garments and I'd knitted this cardigan and was really proud of it it was one of the first you know like wearable like clothes I'd made and then it ended up in a bag that was left on a bus in from like Barcelona airport um I was reunited with it but um yeah that was quite sad when I thought I'd lost it for a few days I think it's gone
社区有什么影响吗？毛线的价格是不是飞涨了，还是说一直比较稳定？我觉得就毛线而言……编织并不是一种获取廉价衣物的方式。我的看法是，这是一种我无论如何都会去做的爱好，而它恰好能产生一个最终产品，这个产品同时也是我可以穿的衣服，这简直算是一个额外的奖金。因为我认为，我编织的动机里90%是为了享受过程，而不是为了结果。但实际上让我对编织感到惊讶的是，它如何改变了我的……我不知道这个词该叫身体形象、自我概念，还是作为一名能够自己制作衣服的人与衣物之间的关系。不过我想，你既可以在一元店买到便宜的毛线，也可以买到手染的、
I love that you got it back how do you even begin to knit a jumper is it like is it stitched together or is it like one thing uh they can be stitched together. I can't quite tell from you. I think your cardigan is pieced. Yeah. But so, for example, this jumper I'm wearing now is cast on the neckline and knitted in the round. And then it's knitted kind of down to the shoulders and then you put the sleeves on hold and then knit down the torso. So it's knitted in kind of three tubes basically um so usually I prefer to knit them kind of all in one piece because you can try them on as you go so then you know if it's long enough or if it fits okay that's easier oh that is just so clever so clever how has the cost of living crisis affected the knitting
超级昂贵的毛线。所以我觉得这里面总有一款适合各种预算。但我想像所有事情一样，可能大多数东西最近都变得更贵了。谢谢。关于研究方面，我脑海深处似乎有一些模模糊糊的事实碎片：那些以特定方式使用大脑的人，得某种退行性疾病的可能性会更高或更低。但我不知道这是不是我自己瞎编的。有没有任何关于编织的、处于你所了解的范围内、真正对我们大脑有益的功能性研究？我想我更多研究的方向是在心理健康方面，也就是关于编织对我们的心理健康有益的研究，而不是
community has yarn prices shot through the roof or are they fairly consistent I think with yarn um there is like the knitting is not a cheap way of getting clothes the way I see it is that it's kind of a hobby that I'm going to knit anyway I happen to end result in an end product which is also wearable for me which is almost a bonus because I think I knit 90% of why I knit is for the process rather than for the outcome but what surprised me actually about knitting was the um my how it's changed my I don't know if the word is body image or self-concept or kind of uh relationship with clothing as a result of being somebody who can make their own clothes um but I think you can buy yarn in a pound shop and you can buy yarn that is hand dyed and um
去思考退行性疾病。但我猜，通常沿着这个思路的研究会认为，使用你的大脑或使用不同的技能有助于保持这些能力。而且这可能取决于你是如何使用编织的。因为我认为编织最棒的一点在于，你和我可以从编织中获取非常不同的东西，并且它能同时满足我们两人的需求。如果你想要的是一种在看电视时可以顺便做的非常简单的事情来放松，那我们其实不需要动脑思考，只需要双手在动。或者如果你想要在参加……我不知道，一场非常漫长的 Zoom 培训时做点什么——那种你只能坐在那里听、而编织能帮你保持专注的场景。如果我坐着听某些内容时手里织点东西，这绝对能帮我集中注意力。你可以这样做。而如果你想要的是我所谓的“主动放松”——
super expensive but um yeah so I think you they can there's something there for every budget but I guess like everything probably most things have got more expensive more expensive recently thank you and in terms of research I've sort of got some vague vague fact rattling around at the back of my brain about people who are using their brains in certain ways are more or less likely to develop certain kind of degenerative conditions but I don't know if I've made that up is there anything around knitting that you're aware of that's kind of in that realm of kind of the actual functional kind of benefits for our brain so i suppose the research i've more looked into is more on a mental health angle so in terms of the research about it being beneficial for
也就是说你想要某种能完全占据你大脑的事情，让你实际上无暇去想别的事，让某些纷扰暂时停止，让你没法去想明天晚饭要做什么、刚见过的最后一个客户是谁，或者任何诸如此类的事情。你完全可以拥有这种体验。所以我倾向于随时在针上同时准备着这两种阵营的项目。我有那种非常简单的项目，可以在例如听孩子们读书时顺便织；或者我可以把它从牙医候诊室里掏出来织。然后我又有一种非常复杂的项目，它会占据我的整个大脑，意味着我只能专注于它，无法同时去想别的事情。所以我想，就研究而言，绝对有研究表明它可以帮助缓解诸如反刍思维之类的问题。所有的这些研究都……
our mental health rather than um to do with thinking about degenerative conditions but i guess generally i guess the research in that vein is that using you know your brain or using different skills is helpful for retaining them and I guess it depends probably how you you're using your knitting because I guess one of the great things I think about knitting is that you you and I could need very different things from knitting and it could offer us both so if what you wanted was something very simple to do while you're watching telly to relax, we don't really have to think about it. But your hands are moving or you wanted something to do during, I don't know, a really long Zoom training where you just have to sit and listen and it helps you focus. It would certainly help me focus if I was sitting and listening to something um you could do that whereas if you wanted something to I call it active relaxation so
你知道的，当研究主题是编织时，想要获得资金支持是很难的。贝森·科基尔（Betson Corkill）可以说是治疗性编织领域的权威，她以前不得不把它称为一个……我记不清她具体是怎么叫的了，叫作“有节奏的双侧心理社会干预”（rhythmical bilateral psychosocial intervention）。每个人都想了解它。但如果她用了那个以 K 开头的词（她对“Knitting”一词的戏称），每个人都会立刻关掉话解，并称她为“那个疯狂的编织妇人”。不过这非常……比如我曾采访过一位肿瘤科护士，她做过一项关于使用编织来缓解肿瘤科护士同情疲劳的研究。她指出，这是一个极易触及的低垂果实（low-hanging fruit），是一种极其廉价、简便且易于提供的干预手段，你懂的，怎么可能会……
you want something to completely absorb your brain so that you actually can't think about something else something is not happening you can't think about what you're making for dinner tomorrow or the last client you saw or any of those things you could have that so I tend to have projects in both camps on the needles at all times so I've got something super simple I can do while I'm for example listening to my kids read or I can whip it out in the dentist waiting room and then I've got something really complicated that absorbs all of my brain and means I can only think about that actually and I can't also think about something else at the same time. So I think in terms of the research there's certainly research that it can help with things like ruminative thoughts all of the research is
它在任何方面都不太可能带来坏处，怎么可能会有什么问题呢？不过确实有过大型的研究，那是定性的研究，我想当时有3000名编织爱好者完成了一项关于……我想他们完成了抑郁和焦虑量表的测评，结果表明你织得越多，它对你心理健康的益处就越明显。但你知道，作为我的播客节目的一部分，人们曾向我分享过一些惊人的故事，比如……减轻身体疼痛、帮助慢性病患者，还有许多人用它来度过丧亲之痛。我想我们也可以从诸如眼动脱敏再加工（EMDR）之类的疗法中借鉴研究成果，因为编织本身确实是一种双侧刺激的形式。我想我们这些每天都在进行编织的人，可能每天都在不知不觉中做着一些类似 EMDR 所做的事情，就用在我们日常生活的点滴之中。没错，完全是这样。所以，我们的听众大部分都是心理健康专业人士，但有时也会有一些单纯对心理健康非常感兴趣的人。因此，如果我简单地解释一下什么是“双侧”（bilateral）——双侧是指我们在同时使用大脑的两侧。
quite you know it's hard to get research funded when it's about knitting. And Betson Corkill, who was basically the authority on therapeutic knitting, used to have to call it a, I can't remember what she called it, a rhythmical bilateral psychosocial intervention. And everybody wanted to know about it. And if she said the K word, as she called it, everybody turned off and called her the mad knitting lady. So but it's very like I interviewed an oncology nurse who'd done a study about compassion fatigue using knitting with oncology nurses. And she said, you know, her point was it's such low hanging fruit, like it's such a cheap, easy and accessible intervention to offer that, you know, what could possibly, possibly you know it's highly unlikely to be harmful in any way um what could possibly be the problem with it but there's big there's you know being a big study that's um qualitative I think that was 3 000 knitters completed a study about I think they completed measures of depression and anxiety and it was kind of demonstrating the more you knit the more likely it is to have benefits for your mental health but you know as part of my podcast people have told me
你知道的，关于编织的研究很难获得资金支持。贝特森·科基尔（Betsson Corkill）基本上是治疗性编织领域的权威，她过去不得不把它称为——我记不清她具体怎么叫了——一种“有节奏的双侧心理社会干预”。每个人都想了解它。但如果她用了她所谓的那个以K开头的词（编织，Knitting），所有人都会关掉耳朵，叫她“疯狂的编织女士”。所以，这很像……我采访过一位肿瘤科护士，她曾用编织对肿瘤科护士的同情疲劳做过一项研究。她说，她的观点是，这就像唾手可得的果实一样，是一种非常廉价、简单且易于实施的干预措施，你知道的，怎么可能……怎么可能……它几乎不可能在任何方面有害，嗯，这到底会有什么问题呢？但有一项重大研究，是一项定性研究，我想大约有3000名织工完成了一项关于抑郁和焦虑测量指标的研究，它在某种程度上表明，你织得越多，对你的心理健康就越有益，但你知道，作为我播客的一部分，人们曾告诉我
some amazing stories about things like um reducing physical pain people with chronic illness um lots of people using it to kind of overcome bereavement i guess we can also borrow research from things like emdr because i guess it is a bilateral, a form of bilateral stimulation. And I think those of us who do it every day are probably doing a bit of that stuff that EMDR does just with the events of our daily lives every day. Absolutely, absolutely. So we have mainly mental health professionals that listen to the podcast, but sometimes there are people who are just really interested in mental health. So if I just briefly say what bilateral is. So bilateral is when we're using both sides of our brain. So
一些非常惊人的故事，比如减轻慢性病患者的身体疼痛，许多人用它来克服丧亲之痛。我想我们还可以借鉴眼动脱敏再加工（EMDR）等领域的研究，因为我觉得它确实是一种双侧刺激的形式。而且我认为我们这些每天都在编织的人，可能每天都在做一些EMDR对我们日常生活事件所做的事情。绝对的，绝对的。所以我们的听众主要是心理健康专业人士，但有时也会有一些对心理健康非常感兴趣的人。所以我简单解释一下什么是“双侧”。双侧是指我们同时使用大脑的两侧。所以
for example, when I move my left arm here, it's my right side of my brain that's doing that. And when I use my right arm, it's the left side of my brain. So when we're doing things like tapping or knitting or drumming or even walking, or therapies such as EMDR, we're activating both sides of those brains. So I love I love that idea for knitting. I think the only drawback I can think about really is if you were going to do that in a forensic setting is giving people potentially quite sharp pointy sticks. But yeah, like, you know know what's the danger you know is you're not going to harm someone by knitting no I think the main thing I found because I've taught lots of people to knit I've done some therapeutic knitting groups in schools and run
例如，当我把左臂移到这里时，是我大脑的右侧在控制。当我使用右臂时，是我大脑的左侧。因此，当我们做拍打、织毛衣、打鼓甚至走路这样的事情，或者进行像EMDR这样的治疗时，我们正在激活我们大脑的两侧。所以我非常喜欢织毛衣这个主意。我想我能想到的唯一缺点是，如果你在一个法医矫治环境里做这件事，可能会给人们发一些相当锋利尖锐的棍子。但话又说回来，你知道，危险在哪里呢，你不会通过织毛衣去伤害别人，不，我认为我发现的主要事情是——因为我教过很多人织毛衣，我在学校里办过一些治疗性的织毛衣小组，还办过
retreats and I think the main um challenge I suppose is when people are already in a period of their life where they're struggling let's say they were experiencing low mood then learning a new thing that might potentially be a bit tricky and frustrating it might be just too hard actually in that moment of their life they might not be able to cope with the kind of setbacks of it's not going to be that easy it might be too frustrating and that's why I guess when I talk about knitting I'm not advocating everybody starts to knit you know when I mention it in therapy I mention kind of I talk a bit about knitting and how I use knitting and I say have you got any
静修营——我认为主要的挑战是，当人们已经处于生活低谷、正在挣扎的时期，比方说他们正经历情绪低落，那么再去学习一件可能有点棘手且令人沮丧的新事物，在他们生命的那个特定时刻可能会觉得太难了，他们可能无法应付那种“事情没那么简单”的挫折，这可能会让人太沮丧。这就是为什么我想说，当我谈论织毛衣时，我并不是主张每个人都开始织毛衣，你知道，当我在治疗中提到它时，我只是稍微谈了一下织毛衣以及我是如何使用织毛衣的，然后我会问：你有什么
interest in knitting and when people say no I then don't talk about knitting anymore but we think about is there anything in your life that maybe you've done before maybe feels familiar maybe you did it in childhood when you were younger because often when I see teenagers they've kind of given up more creative hobbies that they used to do as a younger child because I guess we we offer those things to young children all the time and then I guess we just stop when people get older so often people can think about something that they've done before that uses a similar type of skill something that's a bit creative or it focuses on using their hands like it could be lego or it could be I've got somebody who uses diamond painting who I'm working with at the moment and um it could be yeah it could be painting, colouring, cooking, cake decorating.
对织毛衣感兴趣吗？当人们说不时，我就不再谈论织毛衣了，而是去想：你的生活中有什么是你以前做过的、可能觉得熟悉的、也许你在童年或更小的时候做过的事？因为我经常看到青少年，他们放弃了小时候常常做的一些更有创意的爱好，因为我想我们一直在给小孩子提供这些东西，然后当人们长大了，我们就停下来了。所以人们经常可以想到他们以前做过的、使用类似技能的事情，某种有点创造性或者专注于用手的事情，比如乐高，或者我现在正在合作的一个使用钻石画的人，嗯，还可以是绘画、填色、烹饪、蛋糕装饰。
You know, there's lots of different things that people might find more accessible than knitting. If, for example, they're not, you know, in a period of their life where learning something new feels like easy for them at the moment. Yeah, but there is also that importance of a sense of mastery and the excitement you can get about you know learning something new and what we know um certainly from a compassion focused therapy perspective is that that activates our drive and humans sometimes we can be lacking in drive so that idea of kind of being engaged learning something can be really really really lovely and um over the summer my little boy and I made a few of those friendship bracelets that you kind of weave around a circular thing by crossing the strings and it reminded me that I had a summer of of doing that when I was younger and absolutely loved it and I
你知道，人们可能会发现许多不同于织毛衣、更容易上手的事情。如果，举个例子，他们目前的状况并不适合在这个时候去学习一件觉得轻松的新事物。是的，但这里也有一种成就感的重要性，以及学习新事物所能带来的兴奋感。我们所知道的——当然是从聚焦于慈悲的治疗（CFT）的角度来看——这会激活我们的驱力（drive），有时人类可能会缺乏这种驱力，所以那种参与其中、学习新事物的想法可以非常非常美妙。而且，在今年夏天，我和我的小男孩做了一些那种友谊手链，就是通过交叉线在圆圈周围编织的那种，它让我想起年轻时也有过一个夏天专门做这个，并且非常喜欢它，我
thought oh I should make more of these but um how many friendship bracelets does one one girl need but um you know I absolutely yeah similar to your I used to like Fimo Fimo Fimo whatever it's called yeah Hamer beads like I loved all of that yeah and I think you know we do live in a world where actually you know a lot of well I suppose a lot of what you and I do doesn't have a very tangible product and things like therapy it's you know whether things are going well or you know it might not be very linear progress there might be lots of times with, you know, whether things are going well or, you know, it might not be very linear progress. There might be lots of times where, like, you know, things don't feel like they have a very clear path, maybe. Whereas I think that's part of the appeal of a knitting pattern.
心想，哦，我应该做更多这些，但是，一个女孩到底需要多少条友谊手链呢？不过，你知道，我完全——类似于你，我以前喜欢软陶（Fimo），不管它叫什么，还有哈马豆（Hama beads），我喜欢所有这些。而且我认为，我们确实生活在一个这样的世界里：实际上，你我所做的很多事情并没有一个非常具体的有形产物，像治疗这样的事情，不管事情进展顺利与否，或者它可能不是非常线性的进展，可能会有很多时候，你知道，事情感觉不到有一个非常清晰的路径。然而我认为这就是织毛衣图解的魅力所在。
It is kind of a formula of if you start with this and you do this you get to this and I think one of the other things that's been super helpful for me and for lots of other knitters is the idea of having somewhere to make safe mistakes so it's a kind of part of creativity I guess is trying things and failing in a space that feels like that's safe and acceptable like nothing terrible will happen and particularly for knitting unlike if you were I don't know painting um everything is undoable you can just unravel it and you've always got unless you get the scissors out in a dramatic way what you started with you've still got your two sticks and a ball of yarn so that I think has been really helpful in helping me to grow my kind of self-compassion around making
它是一种公式：如果你从这里开始，你做了这个，你就会得到这个。我认为对我以及许多其他织毛衣的人来说非常有帮助的另一件事是，拥有一个可以安全犯错的地方。所以我猜这其实是创造力的一部分——在一个感觉安全且可以接受的空间里去尝试和失败，没有什么可怕的事情会发生。尤其是织毛衣，不像如果你在画画什么的——一切都是可以撤销的，你只需拆掉它就行了。除非你以一种戏剧性的方式拿出剪刀，否则你开始时的东西、你的两根针和一个线团都还在。所以我认为这对我很有帮助，它帮助我在生活中其他领域的犯错上培养了一种自我慈悲（self-compassion），
mistakes in other areas of my life as well actually because I think the assumption for me and all knitters is that you will make mistakes all the time you know I'm knitting this traitor sweater I unraveled the entirety of it you know yesterday all of what I got to and started again because I didn't quite like the fit of the the roll neck I love that oh I'm looking forward to seeing how your traitors sweater um develops over time I was definitely admiring Claudia's knitwear on traitors um yeah and obviously people can come out and check that out for themselves um where is your Instagram what's your Instagram address, please, Mia? So the Instagram is knitting is therapeutic.
其实也是这样的，因为我认为我和所有织毛衣的人的假设是，你会一直犯错。你知道，我在织这件《叛徒》（Traitors）毛衣时，昨天我把自己织好的全部都拆了，回到起点重新开始，因为我不太喜欢那个高领的版型。我太喜欢了！哦，我很期待看到你的《叛徒》毛衣随着时间推移会有怎样的进展。我真的很欣赏克劳迪娅（Claudia）在《叛徒》节目里穿的针织衫。是的，显然大家可以亲自去看看。请问你的Instagram账号是什么，米亚？Instagram账号是knitting is therapeutic。
Great. And tell us a little bit about your podcast. What's that called and where can people listen? So the podcast is called Why I Knit. And yeah, it's a podcast where I interview each week a different knitter about why they knit and how it benefits their mental health so we've got a very diverse range of knitters some knitwear designers some people who've contacted me to share amazing stories about what knitting has done for them in their lives um so that yeah that's called why i knit and it's available on my website which is therapeuticknitting.org or on any of the major podcast apps thank you so much and you've inspired me i'm going to get my neighbor to teach me how to knit and I'm going to keep you posted and maybe by the time this podcast episode is out which is
太棒了。给我们讲讲你的播客吧。它叫什么名字？人们在哪里可以收听？这个播客叫《为什么我织毛衣》（Why I Knit）。是的，这是一个每周采访不同织毛衣爱好者的播客，探讨他们为什么织毛衣以及它如何有益于他们的心理健康。所以我们有非常广泛的织毛衣群体，包括一些针织服装设计师，还有一些联系我、分享织毛衣在他们生活中创造奇迹的惊人故事的人。所以，是的，这个播客叫《为什么我织毛衣》，它可以在我的网站（therapeuticknitting.org）上找到，或者在任何主要的播客应用程序上收听。非常感谢你，你激励了我，我要让我邻居教我织毛衣，我会随时向你汇报进展。也许在这个播客节目发布的时候——大概
probably going to be around March time I think I will be able to share some progress of my of my knitting along with the socials and perhaps in the editing for this episode super thank you so much for your time and there's you certainly left us with a lot of interesting food for thoughts you're welcome thanks for having me you're so welcome thank you again to our guest dr mia hobbs please do go and follow her over on her instagram account which is knitting is therapeutic you can find Maya there and if you do that you will see that she has finished her traitor's jumper and it looks marvellous now I have to confess my knitting has not got a lot further since we met but I did bump in to a craft group where they were doing knitting in a local library to me and
可能在三月份左右吧，我想我将能够分享一些我的织毛衣进展，以及社交媒体上的动态，也许还会作为本期节目的剪辑内容。超级感谢你的时间，你确实给我们留下了很多值得深思的有趣内容。不客气，谢谢邀请我。非常感谢再次邀请我们的嘉宾米亚·霍布斯博士（Dr. Mia Hobbs）。请务必去她的Instagram账号关注她，账号是 knitting is therapeutic。大家可以在那里找到米亚，如果你这么做了，你就会看到她已经完成了她的《叛徒》毛衣，看起来棒极了。现在我必须承认，自从我们见面以来，我的织毛衣进度并没有取得太大进展，但我确实偶然遇到一个工艺小组，他们在离我挺近的一个当地图书馆里织毛衣，
so I popped in and I chatted to the lovely ladies there and if you're watching on video you will be able to see some of the I asked if I could take a photo not of them but of some of their work and they agreed also gave me a really useful youtube site to check out which is a lady called very pink knits and there should be an image of that on your screen right now they said that there's a really great video on there for how to cast on that uses like a plain background so that you can clearly see what you are doing. So I am going to still run with that gauntlet and I'm going to try to learn to knit and I will keep you posted. Please do come and follow me on my socials to see how that journey unfolds. I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. I'd love to know what you think to this episode. Has it
所以我顺便过去和那些可爱的女士们聊了聊。如果你在看视频，你就能看到其中的一些——我问是否可以拍张照片，不是拍她们，而是拍她们的一些作品，她们同意了。她们还给了我一个非常实用的YouTube频道去看看，是一个叫“非常粉红针织”（very pink knits）的女士，现在你的屏幕上应该就能看到它的图片了。她们说上面有一个非常棒的起针视频，背景很素净，这样你可以清楚地看到你在做什么。所以我还是要勇敢地接受这个挑战，尝试学习织毛衣，我会随时向你们汇报进展。请务必来我的社交媒体关注我，看看这段旅程是如何展开的。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent），各大平台都是这个名字。我很想知道你对这期节目的看法。它
inspired you to get crafty or to bring any of your passions into the therapy room for the clients that you serve? Do come and let me know either on YouTube at Dr. Marianne Trent. Like and subscribe when you're there and or in my free Facebook group, The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. It is my pleasure to bring this work to you. Please do check out The Aspiring Psychologist Collective book and The Clinical Psychologist Collective book and let me know what you need, what you want. Check out The Aspiring Psychologist course for mental mental health professionals which you can do by clicking the link in any of my social media bios i will look forward to bringing the next episode to you as an mp3 from 6 a.m on monday or it's usually available on youtube the weekend before i love
是否激发了你动手的热情，或者让你把某种爱好带进治疗室，去帮助你服务的来访者？请务必告诉我，可以在YouTube上关注“Dr. Marianne Trent”，点赞并在那里订阅，或者加入我的免费Facebook群组：The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent。我很高兴能为您带来这项工作。请务必查看《The Aspiring Psychologist Collective》和《The Clinical Psychologist Collective》这两本书，并告诉我你需要什么、想要什么。通过点击我任何社交媒体个人简介中的链接，查看专为心理健康专业人士开设的《The Aspiring Psychologist》课程。我期待在周一早上6点开始以MP3的形式为您带来下一期节目，或者它通常会在周末前在YouTube上发布。我喜欢
being part of your world i love having you be part of mine stay kind to yourselves and I'll see you very soon take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast that you'll start you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one
成为你世界的一部分，我也喜欢让你成为我世界的一部分。对自己好一点，我们很快再见。保重！如果你想成为一名心理学家，就让这个播客成为你的指南吧，通过开始收听这个播客，你将踏上获得资格的道路，这就是《有志心理学家播客》（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我叫雅娜（Jana），是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《The Clinical Psychologist Collective》这本书。我发现关于所有这些不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的非常有趣。到达那里的途径竟然有这么多，这让我感到惊讶，而且成为心理学家并没有唯一的完美方式，
and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这让我充满了信心，让我觉得“不，我没有做错”，从而减轻了自己的压力。因此，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书来让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书了。本期节目还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。